when you say you curled up in a closet
after you did and this is for the uh the
fall of the house of usher right this is
what you're filming right now is
bombastic as [ __ ]
it's just like insane it's that intense
it's jello which i didn't know what that
word meant until this show what's the
word what's the word
g-a-l-l-o it's a type of filmmaking
that's like suspiria so it's like
extreme
lights and sets and people it's poe it's
like gothic crazy insanity it's chaotic
evil
and
can't hold back there's none of that
midnight mass grounded realism seven
minute monologue thing
it's just like buckets of blood and
people acting in a letter
that
i mean that it just so it terrifies me
like i watch
you know mike's films or at least
the last couple of shows that he did
like uh
the haunting of hill house and midnight
mass and i'm watching some of these
scenes
and i'm going i don't think i could do
this oh my god he's staying on this
[ __ ] actor he doesn't take how she's
oh my god he's been on her for five
minutes she's still talking what is it
when are they gonna cut away why what
are they doing okay i'm getting nervous
for the actor i'm like how the [ __ ] and
i'll tell you why
the preacher in that show
how did he how did they have enough
footage to film
his scenes because he had like 10 pages
straight of monologue i could never ever
do it
he's a genius could you have done that
what hamish did no it's not possible
hamish is a genius like touched by god
genius like i no
because also
fun fact behind the scenes
like hamish wasn't offered that part
like he wasn't the first choice there
was a different look that they were
going for
and
hamish was i believe a fan or somehow
got a hold of the script and was like i
want to read for this
and i had been a fan of hamish's for
years like all the way back some of his
theater work he did a hamlet that i
thought was like life stopping
and
i
begged annie mccarthy the casting
director and mike can i just be his
reader i promise like i'll wear glasses
and a mustache like i just want to see
the man work
and the second he opened his mouth there
was no other choice ever
what he did
was blew every other concept of father
paul out of the water it was brilliant
from the first day did he ever mess up
his lines because i'm watching this
going
i'm not kidding listen listeners if
you're bored tough [ __ ] because this is
as an actor anyway you're watching these
these moments
and you're saying to yourself he's
saying these lines 15 minutes straight
without someone else talking the camera
is always on him it is it's almost like
an impossibility to think you can
memorize that much material i don't know
how people do it you you do it you do it
with a lot of stuff
i think it's similar to any other muscle
i think i'm not shy about it i print out
the pages and i go for a walk and i get
my body moving and i just
takes about
20 minutes of page
that's it 20 minutes a page and you have
it memorized yeah you realize that's a
gift though that's like you must have a
photographic memory or something no it's
a skill
it's a skill i practice it all the time
if i stopped it it wouldn't work i don't
think it what i i truly don't believe
what i do is magic i believe it is
bravery
a little bit of psychosis and practice